I'm a young officer mmm platoon
commander I deployed late
by the time I arrived on deployment
there had been some problems and my
company commander had been set sent back
to the States and the company first
sergeant had been redeployed to another
country now there's a new company
commander and new First Sergeant they're
treating all the soldiers in my platoon
and in in the entire company as if we
are all messed up I don't like their
attitude and my gut tells me there ought
to make themselves look good by
crucifying more people in the platoons I
want to take care of my soldiers how do
i best stand up to the new leadership
all right so I would say the best way
that you can take care of your soldiers
is not to stand up to the new leadership
but instead to build a relationship with
a new leadership you know if you
confront them you confront the new
leadership that's taken over
automatically they're gonna see you as
the enemy right they're gonna see you
whoever got sent home for whatever
reason maybe there was some kind of a
problem maybe there was yeah there's
definitely some kind of a problem
someone got in trouble
something happened bad that's why guys
are getting sent out of country our back
to the States if you confront the new
leadership that means you're on the bad
guys side that's not where you want to
be because if you're on the bad side if
you're on the bad list then they're not
gonna listen to you they're not gonna
trust you and they're gonna be suspect
of you and of your soldiers so that is
not the confrontation in this is not
going to be helpful what you want to do
is if you can build a relationship with
them if you can try and understand their
perspective which is important because
they don't know you get you get put into
a position where you're taking over for
a quote/unquote bad boss mmm or a bad
platoon or a bad company you don't know
what the specific problems are so you're
pretty suspect on everything and you
kinda have to be so that's their
perspective their perspective is like
yeah we don't know what's going on in
here well all we know is something bad
happened they fired the last company
commander they fired the last company
first sergeant something bad happened
here I don't know what it is but I'm not
gonna let
happened to me so I'm suspect of
everything so understand that
perspective and then listen to what
they're saying try and give them some
kind of support right try and gain their
trust mm-hmm so that way they will
listen to you and they will start to
believe you and then you will be in a
protect in a position where you can
actually protect the soldiers right if
you get fired you're not protecting your
soldiers if you go go I'm gonna stand up
for you guys don't worry about are you
going hey you guys you treat my soldiers
bad oh really you're fired and I always
taking care of your soldiers so be
careful of that now you could be also be
right and these guys could be really
really bad they could be out for
themselves out to make themselves look
good and if that is the case well it
still remains that the best possible
thing you can do for your soldiers is to
develop a relationship with these guys
and make sure that as they're trying to
make themselves look good you protect
your soldiers as much as you can and if
they end up being good guys right that
were just like I said just how to coming
into a bad situation well then you've
got an opportunity then you form a
relationship with them and and as you
get through that then you on their good
side you're good to go that way as well
now this is where people get a little
freaked out right because because I'm
sitting here and I'm saying you got to
play the game right
people think I'm saying hey like you
need to brown-nose
yeah hey here's the deal I'm not talking
about that I'm not talking about
brown-nosing I'm talking about being
professional I'm talking about being
respectful I'm talking about being
humble that's what I'm talking about I'm
talking about understanding their
perspective I'm not talking about
brown-nosing I'm taught those things
that's not how you build relationships
and by the way you don't build
relationships through brown-nosing
either mmm wait if you just try and
brown those people they they don't
respect you that doesn't that's not how
you build relations you don't build
relationship through brown nosing all
you do is submit hmm you don't build
anything you're just you're just on the
receive side but if you're respectful
and you're humble and you're
professional that's how you build
relationships
and the better relationships you have up
the chain of command of the better you
can take care of the people below you in
the chain of command that's the way it
works of course this doesn't mean you're
okay if your superiors are doing
something that's illegal immoral or
unethical or or if they're putting your
troops or the mission in danger right
that we're not playing the game
we're not playing the game now you might
still even then have to play the game if
you are my boss echo and you're like hey
I want you to send your guys to Rudd
attack that bunker on the elevated
position right there enemy bunker with a
with a machine multiple machine guns in
it with interlocking fields of fire and
I'm like we're not doing that's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard
now if I tell you I will not do it and
you say okay fine you're fired you come
here you take the platoon and go attack
and now that guy doesn't they all get
killed maybe what I should have done was
like hey echo we shouldn't do that's not
a good plan and you go no you do it
anyways I go stay that's not a good plan
and you say go do it or I'm gonna fire
you okay I'll go I'll go do it and now
when you do it you go out and you flank
you do something different you know you
mean you make something happen you
mitigate the damage as much as possible
mm-hmm so you that's that's a decision
you have to make that's why being a
leaders art because that's a really hard
decision to make right there mm-hmm
yeah that's a tough one yes I remember
at the muster last muster mm-hmm you're
talking about like that that very thing
like you you build a relationship with
them and you know some people every once
in a while I'm paraphrasing kind of what
you said where some people look will
look at it as brown-nosing
yeah and you're like no but it's you
build a relationship with them every
once in a while you might brush your
brush against them you know every once
in a while then I'll come back or
whatever but um but the mission is worth
that you know if I gotta brush up
against brown-nosing just for a second
to accomplish the mission or whatever
then that's what I'm gonna do kind of
thing and that's sort of cleared that
makes that makes good sense and really
so when I thought about that I was like
well really
that is is a lack of perspective or
people forgetting about the big picture
you know tell me what the big overall
thing is we're here to win we're here to
win we're here to win yes but if I got
if I gotta tell this guy he's got an you
know that's a great plan sir yeah that
you you come up with some brilliant plan
sir I'm gonna go and execute that thing
so that he says Oh see jockle gets it
now I'm gonna go let him execute it on
his own I'm not gonna bother him cuz he
cuz he understands my planning and then
I go back to my guys my go ahead here's
what we're doing a little different from
what the boss said but don't worry his
intention was there I'm not talking bad
about the boss way like hey this is what
the boss want to do I think this is how
we're gonna get it get it done yeah talk
about about your boss you just say we're
making some adjustments based on his
guidance usually give him credit yeah
that's how you get it done you brushing
up against brown-nosing a little bit but
again if you're just a full-on
brown-noser you're not developing a
relationship you're just you're just an
ass kisser it's not got a little bit for
you yeah you guys think about this think
about this here's why and I just thought
of this myself here's why a brown-noser
isn't develop relationship and here's
how it's not good to just be a
brown-noser does the superior listen to
the brown-noser does he respect with
their opinion no not really
yeah he's just looking at him like oh
yeah you just let go yep yeah hey buddy
yep yeah you know you can do whatever
say you nice little yes ma'am cool yeah
you give me input I'm like oh thanks a
co that's now hey the big boys are over
here trying to talk can you can you just
excuse yourself yeah I don't want to end
up like that you're kind of the guy who
like you know like the iconic picture of
the guy Fanning the other guy yeah yeah
I'm great like that guy cool to have
around yeah yeah yeah but yeah man but
he's not giving any strategic input on
my operations and not billionaires
relations so yeah build a relationship
man don't confront build yeah we're
distracted by that right the the feeling
you get when this new guy comes he I
don't like the way he said that to me
even though what he said was really
important I don't like the way you said
it
you know what's interesting is when a
lot of leadership books that we've
discussed and a lot of leadership
guidance will say if you're a new leader
coming in you just don't start barking
orders right you just don't start saying
hey do this we're changing that you
assess and you look around and you make
sure now occasionally this doesn't
happen there's things that happen if
you're taking over a totally messed up
unit
or team then you might have to go in
there and lay down some law but
generally you come in and you assess and
you make you then you see what's wrong
you see where some adjustments could be
made now think about that from the other
side from down the chain of command you
also shouldn't jump to conclusions and
be like oh the new boss is an idiot or
new boss has this plan no you should be
like okay let's see what his plan is
yeah you should both have a little
period of like a like a like a cooling
down period but a warming up period sure
the opposite of cooling down so warming
up it's getting to know each other yeah
way out left-field but big shocker Greg
back in time he'd he made this one
comment where he was explaining like how
he rolled with like some make some
payments understand and like he rolls
like oh yeah like how was that you know
you know how you want the full report
like I was it really I forget who it was
what he was like he's like now I was a
full on you know first date roll oh yeah
but and I didn't never heard that before
going to do exactly what that one is
yeah it was like I'm not gonna go hard
in the middle right off the bat he I can
feel he's not going hard and it's just
kind of feeling out you know and a lot
of respect throughout the whole level
does that start out in jujitsu what do
you mean like what what how good do you
have to be in jujitsu before you start
like having a little nice gentler
favorite I you know what I call is
disrespectful yeah like yeah like here's
an example
you just don't dive on the ankle walk
yeah you know two seconds into it yeah
like oh really okay I mean I've had that
happen and then I've had to you know
take appropriate measures right and you
see and you know that fit and that's the
whole reason for the first date role
really well yeah because it's like you
know you start to roll the guy you've
heard of him and he's heard of you and
or whatever whatever the situation is
and you guys roll and in your mind
you're kind of like hey I'm gonna give
this guy some respect and he doesn't he
goes all out first thing it's kind of
like you kind of got you got offended a
little bit not majorly but there's that
little inkling of all all right it's
something it's not nothing
it's something but compared to just some
dude you know let's say we're all
training some
do some new person whatever in the gym
you guys are all been hard it's all good
you're going heart that I know just like
like basically purple belts they're
coming at me brown belts and black belts
you know it's all cool yeah you know
it's like mutual respect and we'll roll
I'm not saying we had am I saying don't
roll hard and I'm not saying you don't
escalate cuz as you get to going you
know like things escalated you know
that's you know you get to know each
other now it's okay to to get after a
little bit yeah that's weird that's a
weird little unwritten thing yeah in
jujitsu isn't it like what I don't
really I guess it's just respect yeah I
think you should respect so yeah do that
up lay down the chain of command - yeah
like it's that first date like period
later you had that period it's get to
know a little warming up here we're not
warming up period exactly give your
bosses that slack yeah
I'll respect all nice you know